what if you don't know your category
what if you don't know how to identify
yourself what what if you're still in a
work in progress if you don't know how
to identify yourself than you don't know
your brand and if you don't know your
brand you won't work create a brand the
best way to do it if you don't know how
to do it yourself you can pay people
thousands and thousands of dollars to do
this or you can work if you're just
starting out take the jobs whether they
pay or not and talk to the DP and the
director they're the ones looking at the
lens sometime you'll do a thing on
camera and you will hear a DP say wow
it's really good what was that thing
what did i do something by some of my
face what was it what was it question
them what is it not what makes me look
good in the frame because that's just
vanity what does the camera love to see
me do how can I make love to the camera
how can I kiss the camera you find that
thing everybody has that thing if you're
not looking for then you're either not
working not talking to the dps are you
just lazy my experience is nobody cares
if you're versatile because everybody's
first so if you can do everything you
can do nothing pick those few things
that you can do extremely well on camera
to the exclusion of everyone else and
promote the Helena so don't say you're a
chameleon no I don't think a chameleon
works again perhaps if you're very young
and very beautiful a lot of this goes
out of the window but I am neither I
can't be a chameleon the casting
directors have to say I want that guy
that has to fill in the blank get me
that guy they don't have time for much
else they're very very busy and you have
to help them you have to be the solution
to their problem
you